So let me just show you some of
the results that you can get using that.
All right?
So here are again, this is taken
from the the Berkeley database.
And because Shi and Malik, Jianbo Shi
and Jitendra Malik did normalized cuts.
And you can see that there
are some pretty good results here.
You know, you like, I especially like
this one here where it breaks up
the picture of the people in,
in a particular way.
Now, of course, these, segmentation
is tremendously influenced by that
affinity matrix, and the affinity matrix
is defined by that distance function.
So, we're back to feature spaces again,
right?
We have to know what features we
should be computing a space over.
We may have to scale the features
because all of that determines
the distances.
But, once you do that and
you play with that,
you could end up with a really powerful,
segmentation method.
By the way,
you'll notice that there are more than,
two segments in these pictures.
Well, so how do you do that?
Well, the simplest is you partition
your graph, and then what do you do?
You partition again, partition again,
and you need a stopping criteria based
upon, sort of the affinities of the,
the links that you're cutting.
Here are some more examples also
taken from the Berkeley database for
segmentation.